it's great to welcome back to the
program today Kelly Weil who's a
reporter at The Daily Beast and also
author of off the edge flat earthers
conspiracy culture and why people will
believe anything uh Kelly great to have
you back on I appreciate your time
thanks so much for having me again so
when you were last on about a year ago
we talked a lot about how people fall
into conspiratorial thinking how
sometimes seemingly benign conspiracy
theories don't sort of stand alone and
they're often wrapped up with other
beliefs that can be more damaging we
talked a little bit about how we can get
people to maybe revise some of their
thinking over the last year we've seen
Twitter in particular change
dramatically in terms of its enforcement
and application of terms of service
under the stewardship of its new owner
Elon Musk and that certainly had impacts
we've also seen platforms like Facebook
and YouTube slightly change if not their
policies at least the way that they
implement or police the terms of service
around conspiratorial or
non-science based content how would you
kind of characterize big picture the
direction that things have gone in these
areas over over the last year
it's a good question I think big Tech
broadly has been stepping away from some
of the misinformation fears that really
characterized around the 2020
presidential elections and you know I
want to give them some credit in the
past but also not too much credit
because
around that election I think a lot of
them were more cognizant of what they
needed to do to combat misinformation
but they weren't doing the best job of
it I think uh some of the best work that
they did to keep the platforms from
going totally off the rails had to do
with a combating algorithms that they
had that prioritize conspiratorial
content I'm thinking mostly of YouTube
which had uh you know recommendations
that put the weirdest stuff at the top
of your feed and although that still
happens to their credit they have taken
action against some of the really
Bonkers stuff it's harder to find Flat
Earth accidentally for example but now
we're kind of swinging back in that same
direction
um you uh pardon me Twitter has this new
for you feed it's a total ripoff of The
Tick Tock for you've created uh you know
guessing what you want to see often you
know our worst impulses do Drive what we
want to see we do want to see the weird
stuff the conspiratorial stuff the stuff
that you're clicking out at two in the
morning so um I do think we are seeing a
maybe a bit lacks or rules on how things
are promoted and distributed on social
media yeah there seems to be sort of
like an air of we're really not going to
be able to stop this and maybe it really
shouldn't even be our responsibility at
the end of the day that seems to have I
don't know if it started when musk took
over Twitter and kind of spread from
there but there seems to be less of a
concern with this
um at least among what I'm hearing
publicly from many of the platforms
yeah absolutely I think there's sort of
a learned help listens there because I
do broadly think that it's true uh you
know social media platforms can't
administer away all the conspiratorial
thinking you know that's a very human
drive we have it's not going to change
if Facebook were to vanish off the face
of the Earth Tomorrow nor really do I
think should they be involved in
litigating the you know minutia of what
we share but there are very deliberate
decisions that some of these social
media leaders are uh taking Elon Musk
you look at who he interacts with and
these are people who came out of like
game or gate blogs right these are
former alt-right conspiracy mongers and
so there's a difference between saying
well you know maybe we'll be a little
bit more libertarian with how we police
things maybe we'll let things you know
hang a little bit looser and Elon Musk
going and like sharing the weirdest
stuff that you'd normally find on 4chan
and you know saying huh interesting
anyone looking into that so you know
it's uh they're not completely as
helpless as sometimes they portray
themselves the anti-vaxx issue has
gotten interesting over the last year
because over time the truth about what
the vaccines do and don't do for the
latest variants has changed and this is
being used by some anti-vaxxers
including those described in a recent
Vice motherboard piece as now wanting
Revenge so-called Revenge because they
feel that they've been Vindicated this
has become a tough one because to take
something as simple as does the vaccine
prevent you from getting the virus when
we go back to that first vaccine and the
first variant the data was very clear
that it did prevent you from getting and
spreading the virus there were people
then saying no it doesn't over time as
the variants have changed and the
vaccine has been updated it's primarily
a tool to prevent you from dying or
ending up in the hospital but now it is
a different reality about whether it
prevents you from getting the virus
things have changed in the real world
the anti-vaxxers have been saying the
same thing for three years it now more
closely lines up with what they were
saying all along that's a really
difficult situation to handle
so challenging and I think it gets at a
reason conspiracy theories are so potent
the reason that we can all fall for them
is because conspiracy theories you know
there's something that we activate when
we do have uncertainty when we don't
have all the informations when something
is frightening in front of us and
conspiracy theories often latch onto a
kernel of Truth or at least a an
emotional truth right and the truth here
is that the vaccines they're not perfect
you know they will keep you out of the
hospital they will make it harder for
you to catch and spread you know this
virus but like you said as the virus
mutates vaccines have been you know
playing catch up and while it is
absolutely a phenomenal idea for people
to get their vaccines get their boosters
it's not going to be the miracle cure
that uh you know we're really hoping for
I want to say like summer of 2020 and so
anti-vaxxers who to your point have
always been saying that you can't take
the vaccine it's you know it's it's
garbage or it's going to hurt you
they've had to kind of tailor their
messaging and say well okay not
everybody dropped dead three months
after getting the vaccine it's not it's
not the zombie apocalypse that we warned
about but it's not working perfectly and
so they take this new reality and they
retrofit it onto what they were saying
to say well you shouldn't have taken the
vaccines and you know I think to that
point about revenge they certainly some
of them I think do uh kind of yearn for
a future where all their political
opponents drop dead because they got in
the backs yeah
um as we've seen the media discussions
of covet more generally
um reduced we also seem to see a little
bit less about Ivermectin and
hydroxychloroquine and urine injections
or nebulizing or whatever you know I'm
sure you saw that guy
um what is what is kind of filling the
void right now I mean I see they're get
they're talking more about Hunter Biden
laptop even though that's a different
sort of thing it's not really equivalent
to you know Ivermectin what what new
things over the last six months are you
seeing getting more oxygen
well I think we're seeing a lot of uh I
hate to say but like Republican cope
with the uh 2022 uh midterms you know a
lot of people not accepting that their
uh their party really didn't sweep the
way they expected so this is going to be
a you know relitigation of 2020 election
fraud hoaxes I'm seeing a good number of
environmental conspiracy theories uh
percolating right now we just had the
train derailment in East Palestine that
of course was the result of you know
huge bipartisan lapses and labor rights
and uh in Transportation laws and you
know the way that these railroads can
lobby but because this is a frightening
situation where it is true our
politicians don't really have the
answers we've seen this void where the
right can step in and say that this is a
plot against you either you know that
they I don't know the the left is
covering up for this or that you know
it's a deliberate sabotage of the
Midwest of of uh Food Supplies that are
really on to that right now this idea
that uh Democrats are gonna like you
know nuke Amish country or something
like that so it's a I think that's
really powerful and that comes I think
in uh side by side with other conspiracy
theories right now that are uh really
hitting back at the idea that you should
be polluting less uh they're really up
in arms right now about the idea of the
15-minute City the idea that you can
walk uh you know you don't need a car
you can walk to the things you need your
child's School the supermarket
um and they're you know calling that a
new world order plot to suppress people
so we I think are seeing a lot of
conspiracy theories that try and um fit
in more conservative ideology into the
reality of this moment where we are
facing fraud and frightening
environmental reality so I think that's
going to be a trend going forward the
other one recently has been the the
quote spy balloon
um and of course I mean anytime you get
anywhere even remotely close to aliens
all sorts of folks come out of the
woodwork but so I don't know if I can
say surprisingly but somewhat
surprisingly you're seeing some of that
come even from marginally more serious
people like are we sure that this isn't
alien life or whatever the case may be
it ended up being a topic
um for Biden's press secretary Kareem
Jean-Pierre talking about it a bunch of
times has anything surprised you in what
we've seen related to the balloons
you know actually yes and maybe it
speaks to a quaint idea of conspiracy
theorists that we still hold where
they're the ones with the tinfoil hats
trying to talk to aliens in their
backyard when we got this uh this
trending topic this idea that there were
UFOs that we were interacting with I'm
like okay well at least we're gonna have
some vintage conspiracy theories we're
gonna have some aliens weirdly enough
people didn't latch on so much to the
idea that these were you know aliens
trying to communicate with us which it
doesn't seem like they were it was you
know often hobbyists balloons are being
shot down but that the balloons were
actually a distraction from something
else oh these were a plot they were
trying to distract you from uh the East
Palestine derailment they're trying to
distract you from reporting on um on a
Russian oil pipeline so it was really
interesting to see the emergence of
something that in the past I think kind
of classic conspiracy fodder and it
wasn't enough in this moment it wasn't
the red meat the conspiracy theorists
were looking for that's another
interesting trait of a lot of these
conspiracy theories you know last time
you and I talked about how
apparent evidence in favor of a
conspiracy theory can be just as useful
as the absence of evidence because the
absence of evidence becomes part of the
conspiracy so it becomes kind of
unfalsifiable in the same way an event
can be
an event you are being lied to and not
told the truth about or the conspiracy
can be the event is real but it's
fundamentally a distraction from some
other thing and it's another aspect of
the sort of unfalsifiability of a lot of
these things
I think that's absolutely right you know
one thing that I struggle with as a
journalist I think a lot of journalists
have this frustration is the idea that
you'll see it on Facebook people say why
isn't this being covered why isn't it
covered and in some respects I think we
do have to take that seriously if we if
people feel like the reality they're
living isn't reflected uh adequately in
the news I think that is something that
we need to take into account but
oftentimes they're saying why isn't this
being covered and you say what and they
link to a CNN article right absolutely
blows my mind but to your point I think
um you know this this idea that you can
you know touch on the apparent lack of
coverage and say that this is indicative
of a cover-up or this is you know
suggestive of another plot really does
show the the flexibility of these
theories uh you know it allows people to
um take their perceived uh the media
that they're taking in and say that it's
part of a broader plot that it's part of
a broader effort to distract you or to
uh steer you in a certain direction and
I think uh a lot of especially a lot of
alternative media folks have really
become quite Adept at taking what the
news media is putting out and saying
that it's part of a distraction effort
or it's part of a you know a a broader
scheme yeah even just the coverage
itself aside from this is the real story
or not or whatever the case may be if
you perceive or claim there isn't
coverage the lack of coverage is part of
the conspiracy and if there's a lot of
coverage then it must be a concerted
effort to talk about that as opposed to
the thing which really should be
discussed so even the amount of coverage
can be used
absolutely again
it's a real frustration you know
ironically right now
I'm reporting in East Palestine and
someone I'm talking to says yeah we're
getting swamped by grifters on the
ground we've got Benny Johnson's on the
ground who are running around filming
videos and look I think you know
fundamentally there doesn't need to be a
lot of Aid there I think people are
rightly uh happy to be getting donations
and stuff like that but you you it's
very easy to turn these things into a
circus over the amount of perceived
coverage or lack thereof or people's uh
imputed agendas when what's really going
on is an environmental crisis with you
know a pretty traceable backstory as to
how it happened yeah even as I receive
emails from people saying it's not
getting coverage I'm realizing
everybody's emailing me about the fact
that it's not getting coverage it's on
CNN it's on Fox News it's in the
Washington Post New York Times
alternative media the story about the
coverage seems to take on a life of its
own
it really does
um and you know I could speculate a
couple reasons why one is you know I
think uh regardless of political
orientation I think we do have an
ambient anxiety about the environment we
know something's up and then you see
something just as uh as shocking as that
big great plume of smoke and that really
grabs attention I think you know the
East Palestine derailment also speaks to
a sort of uh forgotten uh class
narrative that I think uh the right has
become very Adept at wielding without
actually addressing the underlying
issues
um Trump went to East Palestine just
this week when we're speaking um and he
understands that that is you know
predominantly white working color uh
community that that does often
constitute his base and even though some
of the solutions that could help that
Community you know
um
immediate donations now but also you
know longer term investments in Social
programs that would help and that are
very often uh Progressive or liberal
programs it's
having a town like that at the heart of
such a striking uh incident it does kind
of feed into this idea that these are
people who are being left behind in a
way that conservatives can help but
liberals can that's a really interesting
uh interpretation as well which which uh
makes a lot of sense
um the book is now in paperback off the
edge flat earthers conspiracy culture
and why people will believe anything
we've been speaking with the book's
author reporter at The Daily Beast Kelly
Weil Kelly always appreciate your time
and insights
thank you so much for having me